It's coming. We'll have
fuck buddies. They are.
Everyone has guys and girls have
fuck buddies. Yeah, I am. I'm almost,
everyone I know has had one in the past
where you weren't in a relationship with
them. Really the drive over and fuck
and bang and then all right, bye. Yeah,
bye. But you kiss at the end.
That's a lot of checks these days.
I think they didn't even want to see,
they only want a kitchen going to want
to see you. Sometimes you open the door,
the girls, they're ready to fuck and then
just walks off in the other direction.
When you're done, puts a blindfold on
you. Bird boxes are done with us, man.
Fit done. I feel like they're
done. Do you feel like that?
I think it's a precarious time.
A lot of chicks are probably going
Lesbos this week. Oh, it's the dude.
I would be with Trump.
I think the more days that
the the government shutdown,
the more women are going to go lesbian
thinking that hate men so much because of
Trump. They just can't go gay, but
people always say people. Right now.
That's not how I remember what
I said earlier about jokes,
but if what's funny to me
as gay guys are always like,
I'm going to turn this guy out. And that
always sounds alarming. That does work.
But that sounds alarming. Does sound
alarming. But it does work. I have,
I don't want to say I almost said his
name. Uh, he worked on, she wasn't,
he was not an actor,
but he worked in the world of acting
and he told me that he blew a lot of
straight guys.
That was just something that happened.
They would have a couple of drinks and
pretend they'd never done it before.
And next thing you know, yeah,
I got that delicious mouth.
That's what a lot of gay dude say.
It was either him doing them or
them doing him, but he's like,
you'd be amazed at how many, you know,
air quotes, straight guys are out there.
My like, yeah, and he's just knows how
to swing it. But will you, do you think,
is it less homosexual to jerk
a golf with your left hand?
What are you left handed or right
handed? Right handed. So yeah,
if he jerked you off with your left hand,
it's gay.
Or to do it with your right hand
is geared to do with my left hand.
The one that doesn't work as well
cause it'll take longer. Yeah,
but you don't really have,
but it's understandable.
I feel like it's understandable if you
do it with your left hand because that's
barely even your hand. It's my hand, Bro.
You're not going to feel
that much of it though.
She jerk him off with your right hand so
you should be effective and get it done
with. And once you like holding
on Dick's longer, don't come yet.
Hey Buddy, I'm right here. I'm your
pow. I know what's going to happen.
You're going to come the, you're not
going to want to hang out with me anymore.
Oh Gosh. No, no, I wouldn't
do that. Just go fast. No,
I don't believe you. I think
not. I think you, I think you,
I think you said that left hand. Is that
red? That's the party move. You know,
because it's not, you can still use
this hand and to be on your phone.
You can do other stuff,
but then you're not concentrating
on the jerks and the guy off. Look,
once you commit to doing something gay,
just get it done, son. Just get after it.
That's true.
You don't want to be out there halfway
jerky guy off while you're pretending
that you're looking at, you mentioned
this, but also what about this though?
If you are aggressively very
effectively jerking the guy off, right,
and then you can barely use your phone.
It looks like you're just like, ugh,
maybe gay or bi gentleman that's
on some dope or something.
You're doing gay shit with your on your
phone and okay, that's a good sound.
Like it acts as a condom to
prevent you gayness struck.
You're doing gay things mean
you're holding onto a dick.
You just got to accept that and keep
moving. There's a lot of people. Yeah,
you're right.
Just take the next right action.
There's gay people doing shit that's gay.
The straight people doing shit.
That's gay. Everything's
changing now. Jerk that man off.
Once you commit to that project, just
keep going and yeah. What's the payoff?
What do you got out of jerking him
off? I don't know. I don't think I,
let me ask you this. Here's a
question. If there was a place,
is this conversation seem
gay or if life was free,
if you could really do whatever you want,
if you're a grown adult,
you can do whatever you want.
I mean,
that's one of the interesting things about
society is that we set up these rules
and cultures and we decide what you can
do and what we decide is different when
the deciding Hollin is different when
they, and everybody's got different rules.
Yeah. But once we set those rules,
it's very hard to buck those rules.
Now let's just pretend there was no rules.
What if there was a place where guys
would go and guys would jerk them off and
pick new jerks? Yeah. Like if
there was a place where guys,
straight guys got a job jerking guys off,
but you,
it cha you,
you get paid $1,000 an hour,
you don't think the straight guys would
take that job straight struggling guys
then would, they would morph
and figure out a way. Oh,
just over a generation or two.
Just a generation or two.
If you could make $1,000 an
hour beaten guys off. Yeah,
it started as like a
best you can each job.
If you could wear an oven Mitt
while you do it, I wouldn't do it.
Just do we do we figure that out? If you
could wear an oven Mitt while you do it?
No. No warm oil in your bare skin.
That's the only way to jerk guys off.
You got to do a quick bro.
Dude, there's a way. Other ways,
man,
you could definitely do it.
One way you could do is even
you even wrap your hand.
You just do like that release a
sideways like Kentucky Fried Chicken.
There's only one batter.
Crispy batter is bullshit.
Nobody likes that crispy batter.
The Fuck Outta here.
I'm trying to think if I had the jerker
w one thing about jerking off to me,
I feel like there's not as much
calm in your body is there could be.
You know what I'm saying? You
don't get that much at, well,
it depends on what you're jerking off to
and you know how focused you are on the
task. If you're jerking off while you're
looking at your phone, yeah, but you,
you know you're checking your Twitter
and your also beaten up. Yeah.
You're multitask, but you're not going
to get a lot no matter how much you know,
how, how, how, how, how you do it.
Really? Yeah. How much do you get?
You get like a little bit,
how much do you get?
Like if you had compare it to
something like a quarter? No,
probably like maybe a like an
11th of a handful, I guess.
I don't know. How big is your
hand, dude? I can't even,
do you still masturbate as an
adult? No, I do it as a child.
I mean,
I'm just saying I put a diaper on and it
makes me feel like rejuvenating myself.
I feel like you'd rip your Dick off it.
He tried to pass her many routes.
I feel like.